And so if we put the two facts together, we see that every prime factor of N must divide one of the two
expressions in parentheses,
because that's the only way
that N can divide the product.
Now, it could be that every
single prime factor of N divides the first
expression in parentheses and not the second, but for our random A,
that's not very likely. And so when we compute
the GCD in step four, we're likely to get the product
of some of the prime
factors of N, but not all.
To analyze this carefully
requires some number theory, but it is pretty basic number theory.
So if you find number
theory to be interesting and you'd like to learn more about it, try working through this analysis.
Working through things like this is an excellent way to learn more, but I will leave that to you.
And that's the end of the lesson. In this lesson, we covered
the phase estimation problem, how we can solve it efficiently
on a quantum computer,
and how we can apply the solution to obtain a polynomial
cost quantum algorithm for integer factorization.
I hope you'll join me for the next lesson, which is on Grover's
quantum searching algorithm.
Goodbye until then.